for a while you said you felt like you
got almost typ cast pigeon hold whatever
you want to call it siloed as you're the
funny person it's like on Reno 911 they
probably just people love you and then
they think that's what you do right
that's it that's what you do yeah we
know you and we know what you know how
to do and you know how to do that and it
took a long time you know uh to get
people to see me how I see myself you
know what I mean I'm a multiphen it I
can do all the things you know what I
mean don't don't put this baby in the
corner and tell me I'm only one thing
you know what I mean so I but I'm happy
now because I feel
like uh my peers get it yes they they're
like oh okay yeah because it and I'm
curious in that that whole time you just
knew you could do it were you studying
acting at all were you or did you
because initially when you got into
comedy they asked you can you do improv
yeah and and Li and you lied I lied my
way into it but you know what you just
said I could when you had never did you
know what improv was nope okay you know
what's so funny it occurred to me that
is a sign of a that is improv can you do
improv yes I can yeah because that's
what improv is is yes and so of course
you lied to do I lied and then I called
my friend big George and I was like what
the hell is
improv and he was like you know you know
he was like they also wanted me to do
sketch I had never done that before
either but I was like yep you know what
I mean and I just called my friend and
said what do what do I have to do I'm
like oh just be dumb like I always you
know I'm around my house doing the same
you know make me up stupid stuff I'm
already doing yeah I could do that
that's a natural thing that if you if I
didn't know you and you didn't know me
and you were working at a bank and I
came in and we we would start goofing
around the two of us and we'd make
something you know because I would know
right away you'd I'd say something maybe
silly to you and you'd come right back
with stuff that was 10 times funnier and
sillier and before you know it that's
what we'd be doing yeah it would be
that's not because we're in this
profession it's because no do you know
how many time let me tell you something
when the people tell you this call may
be monitored for you know training
person
that's a true statement I used to answer
phones on the midnight shift for a
airline whose name I'm not going to say
and I got in trouble so many times
because it's the graveyard shift and I'm
like I could work on characters while I
answer the phone well guess what guys
you
can't you're not supposed to do
that I'm like good evening where you
want to go
now and that lady in that Tower would
always Point her finger and be like and
everybody would laugh at me because
they're like ah she getting in trouble
again you know and I you know yeah so
yes to to your point if we were at the
bank it's so funny you mentioned that
because when I'm on any call and they
say by the way you know I'm trying to
like activate a credit card or trying to
do something and they say this call is
being monitored I feel I got to take it
up a notch because you know they know my
name and I think well I you know they
might be listening to this later on
Oh no I got a so that's when I start
sticking it up a little bit and
sometimes they're laughing but other
times they're like we just want to
finish this process and no we're not
going to all gather around later and
listen to your really funny observations
about American Express or S you know
MasterCard no hey everybody come I just
talked to Conan he gave me some good
stuff and it's been monitored let's
check it out it's not going to happen
people at work who just want to go home
they just want to home that's it they
want to get this idiot his credit card
activated so uh so you said you could do
improv and then quickly realized yeah be
I can do it of course I can do I'm
figure it out you know what I mean but I
you know it's so funny because when I
auditioned for Reno I did not know
enough to know that you should kind of
like work on a bit you you you should
Workshop it see where the jokes are and
you you know that kind of thing I just
didn't know enough to know so when I got
the call back um I was like I could do
the same thing I did last time I said
but I found this hankerchief in the back
seat of my car and I was thinking about
something on the way over here called
Carol the slave y'all want to see it
they said do we and do it now you know
what I mean and so it was just that by
the seat of my pants because what I knew
for sure I don't know if you GNA book me
on this job but I know my ass is funny
now I now that I do know right so I I
did not fear the thing that I was the
most comfortable in you kind of you kind
of know what I'm saying yeah so you know
Advantage disadvantage I don't know I
just feel like people want to work
getting back to those kids with people
that they like at the end of the day
yeah you know what I mean you you your
first you know uh minute is just to get
them to like you yeah you know what I
mean and not um have that desperation
that up the room like oh my God if you
don't do this I'm going have to move
back to Nebraska next week if you know
what I mean if I don't get this job but
just like this is who I am you know it's
funny because you brought up something
else too which is especially in comedy
but I think true in a lot of things
confidence if people get the sense that
you are okay like if an audience will
look at you and if they know hey I'm
fine with whatever happens I got this
they relax it's kind of a Salesman job
but they relax and think wow ni knows
what she's doing you know we just
brought her in and boy is she relaxed
and boy is she confident it almost it
makes it happen I think Listen My
grandmother used to tell me I remember I
had a baby and baby I don't know what
happened this body ran away from me and
it was it was meaty cheesy and greasy
and I didn't feel I didn't feel
comfortable and I didn't feel confident
and my Grandmama looked me dead in my ey
she said baby when you the only naked
hormon in a room you looks
[Laughter]
good okay
Grandma mik
gir let me take my clothes off right now
you know and sometimes you just got to
you know what I mean you got to roll
with what you got yeah well I've been
doing that rolling what I got um that is
uh that is really I don't know that is
did you get confidence like that from
your mom uh I don't want to make my mom
feel bad but no I didn't it I just
wanted to take a moment and make your
mom feel I know it's different but
you're right after you have a baby
because I had babies a couple years ago
and you're you you feel very differently
about it so it's nice to know somebody
said that to you when you needed to hear
that you know yeah yeah yeah it's all
those confidence boosters how many kids
you you have three you have three kids
and how old are they what's their range
I think my son did he just have a
birthday yeah you know you start to
forget um I have two kids and I can't
even recall their names at this moment
yeah my son is 32 I have a girl that's
27 wow and a a baby girl that's 24 wow
that's I'm just curious if do they love
did did they show the same interest in
doing what you're doing or yes yeah all
wanted to do it yeah but also too I
think when you grow up with your mom on
TV if you're good at your job you make
it look easy yeah you know what I mean
it's like you know my mom can do that I
can do that you know what I mean and it
wasn't unusual to sit down on a Saturday
morning and oh oh my mom is hosting
clean housee that's on skip skip skip oh
Reno 911 is on my mama not going to let
me watch that skip skip skip oh my mama
was in a movie that's on you know what I
mean it wasn't unusual to find me
somewhere on television and so very
early on they all were like o pick me
pick me pick me because they just think
that's normal you made it normal yeah
and it was like that's what I want to do
and so they're all in some sort of
entertainment right now yeah all of them
when my boy was I think he was four
years old and he saw me do some Big Show
in a big venue and afterwards he turned
to my wife and he said when I grow up I
want to do something that doesn't happen
in a theater or with
people thought I thought man I must have
been bad and to his credit he just he
loves comedy and I think he likes what I
do but he's not he just that was not his
thing not his thing but he knew right
away he saw his his dad making a fool of
himself in the on the Beacon Theater in
front of a couple thousand people and
said nope that is not for me I'm not
doing that I love it and I've worked
with my kids too we did a we we had a
reality show at one point together um
and I really only did that for them just
so you could get a taste of it you got
to get up in the morning you got to do
this you know I want to show you what it
is and but all of them have at some
point or another been cast in something
that I've done um my youngest daughter
played my daughter in the series monster
the Jeffrey dmer story that was on
Netflix that was my real daughter she
also played wow okay she also played a
younger version than me in a in a TV
show that I had called
claw and um my middle girl guessed it
with me on um series that I just did
called the rookie feds and so my son was
with me on The Soul Man like they've all
at some point or another experienced it
through your lens which is good uhhuh
you know what I mean and so I was like
I'mma show you but I'm not show manager
you know what I mean and I'm not F to
I'm not going to try to run your career
and tell you what you need to do you
want to do a self tape I read with you
but I'm not calling around town to get
you a job that's your job right you know
cuz when I'm dead and gone if I'm the
only person who ever gave you a job what
are you going to do right you know so
you got to you got to learn it and if
you really want it time is going to tell
that's how I parent well I was going to
ask you for a job but now I'm not going
to well you might be
different no I'm
not